-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"my worst summer job" stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@WorlandJustin.
He said...
[ Laughter ]
-That'll do it.
-Yeah.
This one's from @katiehashtags.
-Wow.
-That's her real name.
-That's her whole family.
She's rich off this thing.
Hashtag fortune.
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
30, 40, 50, 60, 70, 80.
[ Grunts ]
One scoop.
-100, 200, 300.
-This one's from
@Kristinaloree1.
She said...
-Ohh.
-What is wrong with people?
What? Who cares?
A couple broken chips,
you loser.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ThGhstWthThMst.
-Ooh.
-Snap.
-"Who the hell
is she?"
[ Laughter ]
GhstWthThMst, he says...
Ya think?
-"Unkink that hose!"
-You think?
Oh, here's a great one.
This one's from @Lily22307958.
She says...
[ Audience groans ]
-Ohh.
Yikes. Blech.
-[ Retches ]
-Blech. Hashtags.
-Oh, man.
This one's from @Abbygail--
Oh, I get it.
-Abigail. Abby Gail.
-I didn't get it.
I didn't get it in rehearsal.
Now I get it.
-Her name is Abigail.
-@Abbygailm42.
-Mm.
-She says...
[ Audience groans ]
-No.
-That's not an advantage.
That's not cool.
-You need to figure out
a different way.
-This last one's from
@MisterDorngal.
-Oh, I love that dude.
[ Laughter ]
He goes,
"Dorngal, Dorngal, Dorngal."
-@MisterDorngal--
he doesn't do that.
-Yeah, he does. Mister Dorngal.
-@MisterDorngal58.
-Oh, I'm thinking of
MisterDorngal57.
-I got you.
[ Laughter ]
-That guy's nuts.
-He's a Heinz variety.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
he's Mr. Heinz.
-I know.
He says...
That's a bummer.
Guys, those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.